sinner sometimes I get tired of pursuing
my passion of rapping I'm wondering
right now should I take a break or keep
at it if so how long I get afraid of
falling behind much love to you guys
yeah that's a good question sin I think
you know if you love what you're doing
whatever it is rapid let's say that you
probably need to see you really
energized the afresh you really focused
on achieving your goals and invariably
there comes a time where you kind of run
out a bit of energy and you need to have
a better kind of recharge of reflection
so at this point in time you know
whatever works for you you could
vacation whatever you get together with
friends you go team enters you know
whatever it is that really work for you
and then and then I think that's a great
time to reflect on kind of what's
working fundamentally just still believe
in your big idea and if you do what do
you need to change to make it even more
successful and then you can go and get
right back into it this is an
interesting one because we're just about
to release a video on Lindsey Stirling I
don't know if you know Lindsey but Jesus
he's a violinist and she had one of the
top youtube videos for one of her songs
and when she was doing violin she she
kind of got bored of it because it was
kind of classical the same thing and she
just grew a little tired of it and she
wanted to put it down and then she
discovered electronic music and Skrillex
and DJs and all these people like
putting out beats and she said that'd be
really cool to combine my violin with
the electronic beats and she formed a
new things that hadn't existed before
and that reignited her interest in
fashion in violin and also helps
differentiate yourself and create one of
the top youtube videos for music videos
and so on wondering if they're there
might be something like that in it for
you where if you still love wrapping but
you're not you know you don't like doing
it the way you've been doing it or wait
other people are doing it to explore
make the combine it with
another passion of yours to continue to
test the waters you know if you look at
the Beatles none of their albums sounded
like each other the first album was way
different than external a different the
next one and people are like well why
don't we like the early Beatles why
don't you keep doing those like well
we've grown as people we don't we don't
do that anymore we want to do new stuff
and I think that's part of every
entrepreneur especially artists you have
to continue to evolve and test and try
new things and so if you're getting a
little bored of what you're doing I'd
say how do i mix in something new trout
in the project that still involves the
rapping but you can involve incorporate
something else in it to push yourself
and see if it makes it come alive yeah I
think that's good Evan I think all serve
you if you really get in thought go and
kind of go go round and listen to rap
you really respect go meet someone maybe
maybe think about doing something
collaboratively with a partner because
it sounds like you just need new
innovation sounds like you got a core
idea you love what you're doing but if
you need to evolve it there's the loads
of changes